this evening informed by the data that
we've just seen i can
announce that greater manchester will
move to the very high
alert level that means that pubs and
bars must close unless they're serving
substantial meals
households can't mix indoors or in most
outdoor settings
in some public outdoor spaces groups
must be limited to the
rule of six and we strongly advise
against travel
into and out of the area in line with
the
additional measures taken in lancashire
casinos bingo halls betting shops adult
gaming centers
and soft play areas must also close
regulations will be laid in parliament
on thursday and come into force
just after midnight i know that these
restrictions are tough both on
businesses
and individuals and believe me no one
wants to uh be
putting these things uh into effect but
that's why we're also enacting a
comprehensive package
of support the job support scheme
ensures those affected by business
closures are still paid those affected
by business closures are still paid
and once you top that up with universal
credit those on low incomes
will receive at least 80 percent of
their normal
income over the last 10 days
we tried to get an approach with local
leaders in greater manchester
uh a joint approach unfortunately
agreement wasn't reached and i do
regret this as i said last week it would
have been better and
we would have a better chance of
defeating the virus if
we work together in addition i must say
to the
support outlined above we made a
generous and extensive offer
to support manchester's business i want
to stress
this offer was proportionate to the
support we've given merseyside
and lancashire le mayo didn't
accept this unfortunately and given the
public health situation i must now
proceed
with moving greater manchester as i say
to the very high
alert level